hello everyone welcome to my site my
name is mark pickup
i'm the ceo of nova science uh here is
spinoff from boca
university and my talk today
will be about hybrid modeling and
intensified kind
of experiments basically i'm currently
my home office
but i dressed up for you when you see a
have a nice view to the outside
but okay so let's let's directly jump
into the topic
actually right now we have a huge crisis
corona crisis and one of the problems we
encounter right now is that
there might be a vaccine on the market
in one to two years but normally when we
talk about
medicine development for for the market
the normal timelines are around
10 to 14 years which is a huge time
spent
and the development process itself
consumes something like two billion
dollars that means one such a drug is on
the market
it comes up with quite a huge price tag
per dose it is
at the end satchel sets huge suppressor
on the
on patients and also on the health
system so
i think we're in a stage where we really
have to speed up this process
and in order to speed up this process we
have to consider actually what are the
bottlenecks so when you when you look at
this simple sketch you see that
from a new molecule or a biosimilar
there are actually two streamlines at
the same time the one side is the
bioprocess dealer or the process
development
and the other side are the clinical
trials and as i said this time span is
still 10 to 14 years
and we have to ensure we have to find
solutions to speed up this process
okay so our aim is to significantly
reduce osteoporosis development
and also the clinical trials so from the
from the whole perspective of mankind
and this will have two benefits on the
one hand we would have earlier
patients treatment especially now if you
consider corona
i think this is quite clear but also it
would lead to
significantly higher return of invests
for companies
because if you enter the market earlier
with your biopharmaceutical
with your truck you have a longer time
spend until you're
uh until your patent protection runs out
and you can supply the market
alone so this is also a huge benefit for
for companies
so we have to reduce both of this of
these timelines
simultaneously in order to do so
you have to somehow consider the value
chain uh
and the last point in the value chain is
the last one is
actually the patient so the patient if
you consider the corona has a problem
and so has a request and you need a drug
to treat
this patient and on the other hand you
can think about the drug
or the product must be fit for the
patient
and you can consider this something like
the uh the
technical trials as well you have to
make sure that the product fits the
patients
and there is what this continues also
the product has to be
has to fit is the process and finally
the process has to fit
the class or something like the inverse
value chain
and currently there are a lot of
initiatives uh speeding up this process
from different
from different perspectives and we call
this we can call this
frame of digital uh transformational
digital twins
and for all of these particular parts
there is uh
there's actually a lot of development to
the legal digital twins so you can
consider like
like a patient data you can do a lot of
patient data you can think about
molecular modeling you can consider
models about the process but you can
also consider
these building information models where
a lot of different vendors can work
together in a single plant
and can deliver can deliver the
construction of the plant much faster
than it was before
so there are like there are actually a
lot of tools around the market to speed
up all of these different
uh different topics and you can for
example think about
google deep mind they are really strong
in
machine learning from foundation data
you can also consider what we are doing
and what this might be what my talk will
be
about today is about the relationship
between the product and the process
and we use hybrid modeling here to speed
up the process development so we are
only on the process development side
or on the process side and not on the
clinical side but you can also think
one step further and you can circle
there are also tools out there and maybe
this is not a comprehensive comparison
but there are just
three tools to make an id to give you an
idea of
what's out there and on where this tool
is addressed on different levels of the
process
you can also consider like what siemens
is offering cement it's an
engineering plant simulator which might
help you with digital conditioning
and you can also speed the time you can
also speed up timing of plant
construction
okay so coming back to what we are doing
with nova scientific process modelling
so when you consider
there's a certain there's a certain cell
and from this other certain process and
at the end of the process there's the
medicine
and what we are doing is we're speeding
up this process
using our advanced machine learning
tools
when we look at operations which are
currently
out there used for for biotechnology i
would say there are three
three main topics there's the upstream
topic for sure you are
the bio process you have to produce is
somehow in cells
so option processes everywhere
second thing is filtration which in
every process always there's
at least one filtration step either for
separation or for concentration
and finally also chromatography in red
files and we also always have
chromatography
and white biotech it's not so often but
still
over the whole frame of biotechnology i
think these three unit operations are
driving
the market so and today i
want to show you two show cases one is
for the upstream bioreactor
and one is for the filtration process we
start with the oxygen bioprocess
and here i have a showcase from an
acrylic wet batch cultivation i can
delete the reactor
and what we were interested there is we
had three
critical process parameters temperature
feeding rate and induction strength
and these three parameters were supposed
to drive the
uh the particular distributor quality
attributes which are in this case the
biomass
and the product so if you look at this
design space it's quite clear
that this is an immense experimental
effort because each of these points
represents
one experiment and one experiment here
and this equally cooperation is one week
not as long as cho but still if you do
all of these experiments that means you
have
to do 27 experiments which costs you at
least half a year of experimental work
to understand the whole design space in
the full factorial way okay
what people are currently doing or often
doing is to take ordinary
poe tools so they have the design space
then they perform their experiments
and then they look at the end point so
the end point of the process
and they're building a model you can use
jumps on expert matlab there are
a lot of tools actually you can build
the model to describe
uh the relation between the inputs and
the outputs often for the end point
but there's actually a limited course
kind of thing and if you only look at
the end point and you do not
model the whole process in a timely
manner and as an example you can see
this here so if you have a response
variable
might be the title over the process time
and let's see this is a comparison of
four different runs
when you look at the end point there are
actually infinite possibilities of the
trajectories how you start for how you
get from the start to this end point so
let's say for this particular round
you might have these three options and
if you do not sample over time
and the next step if you do not take a
model over time you have to somehow
if you do not if you do not model over
time
you have this somehow called theory
knowledge there
so if you model over time let's say this
is the true right you know
this is the trajectory this is how the
how the process develops
and if you look at this over time first
thing you will realize is okay there's
no need to have this process for this
particular time because if you
stop earlier you might have the same
process here at the air end
but the time the time spent title
spacing is much higher because we don't
have to
you know perform the whole round it's
the first thing
and the second thing is when you also
take samples over time you can really
build up a
very valid process model which describes
the whole process and this
in our case was done by hybrid modeling
and you can see this here so we have
three input parameters temperature feed
and induction
so it has a little
never mind we have these three inputs
temperature feed and induction and these
three inputs
they are are used in an island
and these artificial neural networks
then predicts two
the first rate is the growth rate the
new and the other rate
is the product formation rate and by
doing so
we feed these rates into a mechanistic
model
and this mechanistic model speeds this
whole
model a certain structure and this is
why it's called hybrid modeling because
we have the in which is a black box
model or a data learning model
and the other the white box is
driven by differential equations here
and as the output
we have two output variables one is the
biomass and the second is the product
okay and by doing so and comparing the
outcome
of process modeling from hybrid modeling
with pure black box modeling over the
whole time domain
you can see here in a simple example for
example you see a biomass prediction on
the scatter plot
for the pure data driven model
and what you see is on the x axis
basically is the measured value and on
the y
axis you have to predict it where you
buy the model
so if you would have a model that
perfectly fits all of your data you
would have straight line
however we also know that we have a
certain analytical uh
impreciseness so we don't know there's
an inaccuracy in the measurement
we know for example for the biomass we
did this in our experiments
where we performed seven rounds the same
way and then you can see for each of
these points
you can measure the biomass and you can
see how much the deviate
and now is something like five percent
so you can see that uh
what you can see from this comparison
between the pure black box model and
hybrid model is that the hybrid model
due to this given structure we
introduced
by the mechanistic equation the
predictability of the outcome is much
higher
and you can also see this in terms of
the pi domain so while
in the upper the upper graph there was a
scatter plot you see when you take one
of these runs
out of the scatter plot and plot it over
the time domain
you can see for example how the how the
pure black box model performs over time
and how the hybrid model performs over
time and we also
what we also did is we uh aggregated
several models that
means we put the bootstrap approach so
you take several models and we take the
average of these models
and then this average of this model
features somehow
confidence interval of the models it's
not the real confidence interval but it
says okay how many different models you
have
and what do these models predict so if
this confidence interval
of the models is quite broad that means
all of the models are quite different
and if this confidence interval is very
small it means your models are quite
similar
and not only that the hybrid body can
predict the trajectory of the real
biomass samples which are obviously
these
these points here or these triangles
here
and so not only you can predict better
the real trajectory but you can also all
of the models or the different models
they're much more similar than for the
pure black box model
so this is one of the learnings here but
right now
what we did so far is we were able to
describe the process which is nice you
get more
you get you are able to describe the
whole process but you didn't save any
time
so my initial argument was to save time
and this is what we really want to do
right now we just described the whole
process but highly modeling
in in this case here is like the
commodity so you have to describe the
whole process first and then
when you're able to do this or if you
have a tool that is able to
accurately describe the whole process
you can go one step further
and really save time this is what i will
show you now
we have the approach for intensified
design of experiments what does this
mean
when you have a full factorial design
space what i told you before
these 27 experiments each of each of
these points represents one experiment
we have 27 experiments to conduct
means half a year of work okay to screen
the whole design space but what you can
also do is you can take a functional
factorial design space that means you
take out some of these rounds and you
only perform in this case
uh only the borders only this uh four
points in the pot
and the four points in the bottom plane
and the center point
so that means we are doing so you save
66
of the experiments and the questions do
you learn the same then
if you would take the 27 experiments
this is basically stunning industry also
quite often because if you consider a
siege of fermentation for example where
you have 67 parameters you change
on three levels so you have three to the
power of seven
you cannot do a full factorial design
space because you would this would take
infinite time so
so you have to take points out and you
have to uh
reduce the number of positive
experiments you can either do this with
the functional approach
but what you can also do is you can
consider this intensity for this kind of
experience
what you do here is to try to still
do all the experiments in the design
space but not
each point represents a whole run but
you change process parameters during the
cultivation
so what you can see from the from the
blue plane for example is
all of the nine points in the blue plane
are covered by one of
the one of these lines so a line starts
in a certain point
and then covers three of these points
that means we start with a single
uh condition and after a certain time in
our
in our case we change after one doubling
of the cells
we switch to new cultivation condition
and then we switch again to new
configuration conditions so in our case
we did
two switches for each of these media
videos and if you do so you
also have only line experiments that
means you also reduce
the total amount of experiments by 66
but you somehow learn from still don't
understand design from the from the
whole design space
this is called intensive by design of
experiments
then you can make a comparison for
example if you compare the three tools
the doe
only at the end point because we just
look at the endpoint for this particular
thing now we want to look at the end
function theory
we compare uh the moderate ability
by taking all the points
in the argument and also doing hybrid
mode which is intensified design of
experiments so while
we have the dve 31 experiments in the
training set
and hybrid model we took 25 minute
training set
training validation 76 in the test set
and in the hybrid mode we only have nine
and for test the hybrid model what we
did here is we took
the hybrid model from the intensified
drone so the nine runs
and built the model and tested this
model
then on the 20 or on the 31 experiment
so the reason why here 31 state
is that we performed some of this
experiments as duplicates
so therefore we don't not only the 27
experiments but the
full design space was 31 experiments but
still covering
the whole points i described here and as
i said what we did here
is we performed the hybrid model on the
data from the edo so we built the model
on the ideal data
and then we took this model
and predicted the
concentration for the biomass and
product on the on the
static day design of experiments on
there on the full factory design of
experiments
and when you look at it later you see
that the normalized wooden square arrow
is lowest for the puree point but this
is also clear because you only look at
the plane you only look at the endpoint
for the hybrid model and the edo we are
able to describe the whole process so
the area is a little bit higher but you
can
you can describe the whole process it's
the first thing so you have an entire
process model is a huge advantage
and second when you look at the time or
if you look at the
required experiment it just represents
the time it also represents the cost you
have to do in your lab
it means you can significantly save time
here
and finally what you can do with the
whole process model you can also use it
for soft sensing so you can
implement soft sensors and i will show
this to you afterwards
you can implement soft sensitive enabler
next step you could
also go for advanced process control so
you have a body you
build the model in the design space you
learn from it and then you can also
transfer it to the shop floor or if you
are already doing a verification lines
on the shop floor you can also use these
modis
uh for for soft sensing in real time
okay so this is for the biomass
but you can also look at the product
where we have a similar picture
however the normalized human square
error is a little bit higher
this also comes from the fact that the
analysis is not so accurate compared to
the biomass analysis here
but apart from that you see a similar
picture
okay then let's go to one of the
one of example just for a single one so
this is just a single run over the time
domain you can we compare the three
different outcomes from the
from the hybrid model built on the full
factorial design space on the hybrid
model built from the intensified
kind of experiment which is the green
one and the hybrid model built
only on the fraction of the sign space
which is the red one and you can see
that for sure
the hybrid model built on the full
factorial design special which is the
blue one
performs best for sure you learn from
the most you have the most data to learn
from
if you consider the ido e model which
you learned from the nine ideally ones
also is quite accurate and also the uh
the bars
of the model are not as broad as for the
um
or the functional factorial design space
and the huge benefit is so you learn the
whole design space you take up the whole
dynamics from that
and you save 66 of the time which is a
huge benefit
okay coming to the soft center
application uh
as i said we just built this model you
just built this model based on these the
edo iran's and
you can transfer it back and you can say
okay why not doing something different
or why not performing uh experiments in
the lab or in the
on the floor wherever you are and use
these models as soft sensors so that you
have a real-time prediction of your
biomass and your product
during the new configuration okay and
this can be done quite easily so we have
a
hybrid modeling toolbox to build this
model
inside our hybrid modeling toolbox you
can export this model
as a dla file and then you can import it
and put your
at your environment which you are using
in our case we're using
even some control and we we are
importing
in even some control uh the dll file
from our toolbox
and i can show you afterwards how they
are
how this soft sensor performs okay so
this is the slide of soft sensor
performance normally this would be a
video however i cannot
play this video here but i have a qr
code for you so if you're interesting
you can just scan this quarter
with your phone you will be directed to
youtube and on youtube you can see how
this propagates on time so this is a
prototype
uh what you will see is for example here
you have the
temperature so this noise is looking at
just the temperature and here we have
the shift that means this is an
ideologue we perform the new idea we
want and you can see for example here
temperature shifted
that's why we have this when you look at
the core the red card for example within
the biomass you can see how the biomass
propagates over time
and the yellow curve which starts here
at
4.5 would be the product which would be
which also goes over time you can also
see how the product propagates over time
in real time so this is the soft sensor
in real time check out the video you
will see at the beginning of the video
how the dll is imported
how the model parameters are mapped with
the opc parameters so the three model
parameters we have
are mapped with the corresponding c
parameters in the environment
and then you just start the cultivation
and this pc time lapse how this
propagates over time okay however i also
have
the outcome of this for you in my next
week
slide as i said we performed the idioms
on this
on this design space and then what we
did with the soft sensor here we
performed a complete new round so we
the different idea we run we start with
this condition after one generation
we switch to this process condition and
after another generation
we switch to these process conditions
okay
you can see this here so while uh you
have the prediction of the soft sensor
in black this is what the soft
sensitivity time
you can see what the offline
measurements afterwards in uh
in yellow um speaking of real
these are the real numbers compared to
the soft sensor numbers and they're only
the
advantage is obvious while the soft
sensor is in real time you have this
number
right away the yellow the yellow uh
real-time measurements probably wanted
to basically
uh this is the first thing and the
second thing is that this soft sensor
how the speed is also a
predictive soft center that means you
can simulate because our input is the
feed
the temperature and the inductor and you
can simulate how much you'll be feeding
to your
process in the future that means you
also get this curve already for the
future
this is also a huge advantage if you
build models with a valid
model structure and the inputs are
factors that you can control if you take
an input factor for example from from
from some spectroscopic measurements you
have other advantages but the
disadvantages
you cannot within the future because you
don't know what uh what the signal will
be in the future and also when you look
about when you think about
uh predictive control and you also
cannot change the signal of the
of the parameter for example in order to
get more product out of it you can only
do this if you build your model
based on variables you can control okay
here you can see the same for the
product
it's also quite accurate however
deviation at the end of the process we
cannot really say
if this is either from modeling accuracy
or or
there was something wrong at the end of
the process but actually
you can see also
okay so summing up the upstream part
this hybrid model is more suited to
describe firebases is from
the ue blackbox modeling second the id
we significantly save
process characterization times and
thirdly
um i hope i could show you a simple
implementation of the soft sensor at the
shop floor
uh or at the floor or wherever you want
to apply it on and it can be
easily used to access both the biomass
and the product
in real time in this particular case if
you have other processes very important
if you have other
quality attributes you're interested in
and you measure them you could also be
depending
okay now coming from a different topic
now i think i could join the upstream
topic
why hybrid model is very useful there
and how this could speed up your process
the second thing is now the downstream
showcase where it is about conventional
flow filtration
just as a short reminder what is
conventional filtration
you have a certain target of interest in
a certain
in your tank you concentrate this in
that means you
you pump your solution through a
membrane cassette and everything will be
smaller
then uh everything that is larger than
the pore size of the
membrane concept stays inside this
inside this is flow
and everything that is smaller just goes
through the membrane that means you
concentrate your putting solution in
and this is a time depending process and
there are a lot of
parameters that are that are responsible
for these permanent flux
the permanent flux with what goes
through the membrane and in our
case we build the model based on the
cost flow so the cost plus one equal
parameter the transparent ground
pressure is one into parameter and
the target of interest is for sure one
target one meter
so here we go and the objective of this
is to have
a prediction of the duration so we want
to have a prediction of the duration how
long this process might last under
certain conditions so let's say we have
a certain tp a certain concentration and
the second cost flow how long will this
process last
and for different concentrations so
let's say you have a certain variation
in your process plus minus one gram
from coming from a certain column then
you also have different outcomes so
if you have a model that can describe
the variation on the sample contribution
you can
take action and you can change them so
we want to build a generic model
the second thing that is usable that can
be used in different
operation mode i will explain what i
mean by this afterwards
and developing a digital experience at
the point
okay so the hybrid model structure here
is
somehow similar to what this is upstream
we have three inputs t and pcf
and concentration we predict the flux
and the flux line goes into the mass
panels and from this mass balance we
calculate
the concentration at a certain point
when you take this concentration put it
into the multi step and the hybrid model
and do the same thing again and by doing
so you could look into the future how
your process will develop and i will
show you this
in this sketch so what you will see here
is you have our you have the tank where
you have your protein of interest is the
yellow thing to the left
and when you start the process this
volume will decrease
and also the flux will decrease so when
we have low voltage concentration with
the high flux and the higher the
protein concentration side where the
system gets
the lower the flux gets and you will see
so for example that you see right here
this is the outcome of the body so you
see
what your model will predict under these
conditions for the future
how long this process will take in this
case 70 minutes or 50 minutes
and then you start your process and what
you see now is the really processed
materials in the real data and this is
how your paper operates over time
so you see that this model is quite
accurate and it's easier than any
upstream because the
uh uncertainties are not so high in the
upstream the things you're looking at in
the model parameters which also are
really
almost 100 essentially described in the
process
okay so this was for a fat patch
configuration but you can also use this
model
with low error here typically
you can also use this model for
different data operations
this is something that is typically
often done in a large scale because you
have
a small tank and you have a large surge
tank where you have a higher volume in
there
so overall the volume is too high for
the small tank that means
you're concentrating in the tank and the
volume that goes to the hearing
aid is filled up again by the search
tank and by doing so you see a different
behavior so you see this up
on the upside here top right you see
that
uh while the search tank there's still
volume in there
it's quite a almost let's say that
certain linear line
and once the search tank is empty you
can see that there's a steep increase
or a decrease in internet box
and the power here is that we we learn
from the data but due to the fact that
we build a hybrid model we are able to
protect both
the batch the vegetable also
what we're currently working on is sorry
this is the second part now
in the second part now uh
decrease
you can see a similar error here for
different process conditions
okay but when you have this hybrid model
that describes the relationship between
your membrane
and your protein you could think about
this in general there's a different
operating moment you can also think
but still due to the fact that you learn
from the behavior how your membrane
reacts to the protein
you have a very high learning rate and
you can extend this model on different
operations most would
not be possible okay finally
we also have the digital twin
application here and this is what i said
before
the fact that we learned from the
behavior of the membrane
you could also model different
situations so let's say okay now you
have
different concentration starting
concentration but you want to keep
the process still at 40 40 minutes if
this is a time slot you're interested in
you can consider how you have to change
the tmp and the gross flow
in order to finish also after 40 minutes
and you can see a simple example
in this sketch so the algorithm iterates
through so let's say we have a one
liter reservoir and we want to be if we
want to finish up the 30 meters so the
algorithm
iterates through until it finds the
optimum conditions to stop after
to be finished with a certain volume
that you set up
front you finished after 14 minutes and
with this digital clean application you
can really model your processing in
order to
to deal with different situations so if
your different
situation where you have a different
okay so this brings me to the results of
the downstream topic
is we have a multi-step ahead hybrid
model that completed the outcome of the
of this process already at the very
beginning of it
uh it's a very small training that is on
the sufficient so you can do
normal tnp explosion as you are used to
in industry the only thing you have to
consider is that you need a device that
is able to
uh keep the tnp
as a dnp controller because if you do
not control the tmp at the end it's
clear
you have two variables that you don't
know you cannot run this process so you
have to have a system that is able to
uh to keep the tmp constant over time
okay and then the flux revolution over
time was modeled and
ideal time point for df for example
could be estimated so let me say you
have
you know the ratio where you want to
change to df
then you already can not can describe
this
okay and also between application but
actually is that with this simple thing
you can
up front five minutes before you start
your process you can set the other
conditions you want to have in the
process and at the end it will lead to
your
desired uh outcome
okay
we are currently developing hybrid
modeling toolbox which could be used by
every one of you if you're interested in
just go to our
uh home page nova sign up here and you
can download these toolbox
for free so there's a free version
basically it's a three new concept so
you can always use it for free there's a
limited version
it can be used for for your process
mainly we're focusing upstream processes
but currently we're also integrating uh
what i just showed you in the downstream
which is currently still in the matlab
inside inside our hybrid box and we also
have a support
support portal where you on the one hand
can track your own progress
and what the other one is if you don't
have any questions
now because i'm at the end of my
presentation i would like to
thank you if you have any questions i
think my email address
will be given to you so you can always
contact me or you can use
you can use our channels like in twitter
bye